uh if you were betting on the jets
cutting le'veon bell going into the
season and i'm sure somewhere somehow
there would have been a prop bet that
you could make the over under on when
the jets would cut lava mobile i thought
they would trade him they probably
sought the thoughts so too shireen they
tried they failed he's now officially
out you know it's something that if you
had told us
before
uh or back in early 2019 when he signed
with the jets that it wouldn't last even
a season and a half we'd all been
shocked if if we had been informed that
was going to happen but here it is he's
out and now he can go wherever he wants
it's crazy and i guess at some point you
just realize enough is enough and you
move on we've seen it with a b and it
amazing these steelers players all leave
and and fell elsewhere it tells you what
a good job i think that mike tomlin did
in pittsburgh when he had both a b and
le'veon bell because they came became
too much for their teams to handle and
in abe's case multiple teams to handle
and they've moved on but it's going to
be really interesting i think to see
where le'veon
lands you know we all thought when earl
thomas got cut oh he's going to have all
these opportunities and nothing i mean
crickets now with earl thomas we almost
forget he's out of the league so who's
gonna jump on the le'veon bell train and
and think he can help him that'll be
interesting
well and remember when leonard fournette
was cut by the jaguars we didn't know
how long he would be available once it
started to get out that the patriots may
have interest and the fact that it got
out means they never had interest
because it never gets out when the
patriots are injured in someone they
just sign it because they tell everyone
involved if it gets out we're out uh
once that got out though
fournette lands with the buccaneers and
some people in the league think that
bell will end up with the patriots i
don't know about that but there are
teams that could use him i'm still
surprised sharim that they didn't squat
on le'veon bell in new york until the
trade deadline because you've got week
six week seven week eight
running back suffers a serious injury at
some point over the next three weeks all
of a sudden there's a market for le'veon
bell when there wasn't one before and it
just tells me how bad it is or was
between player and team and also
with their
miami game shifted around in their bye
week moved from week 11 to week 10 as
part of the fallout of rescheduling the
broncos patriots game adam gase now has
four chances left to win a game before
it's
a done deal if it isn't already that
he's out
at week 10
and
uh there there are some games coming up
that that i think they could easily lose
of the next four i think they could lose
all of them they they should lose all of
them it's dolphins i think it's chiefs
bills and uh maybe patriots before the
buy so
to the extent that playing the game of
keeping le'veon bell around was going to
create some sort of a distraction that
would have made it harder to win
let's just cut the chord let's just move
on who cares if we would get a seventh
round pick gates isn't going to be there
to use it anyway if they don't win a
game so see you later le'veon and let's
focus on the guys who want to be here
and mike i think i've slowly come over
to mds's michael david smith our
co-worker i've come over to his side
that
running backs or a dime a dozen i mean
look at what's gone on in carolina
without christian mccaffrey they've done
just fine without him and it just seems
like you can find running backs anywhere
and plug them in and there's some really
good ones you can get late in the draft
or you can get in free agency for cheap
or you can
whatever i mean they're all out there
and and there's a ton of them so to go
pay a running back a lot of money and i
realize in le'veon's case they're not
even gonna have to pay him a lot of
money because the jets don't owe him
this money but to pay a running back a
second contract maybe just isn't worth
it maybe that's what we're seeing here
in some of these cases when you go look
at todd gurley and you now look at
le'veon bell and and some others we've
seen ezekiel elliott frankly hasn't
living lived up to his contract in the
year in five games that he's been in
that contract
there aren't many teams that are happy
with the second contract that they've
given to a running back the vikings and
adrian peterson may be the lone
exception that one still didn't
run all the way through conclusion
unlike a quarterback contract would do
and the problem is you s you create a
superstar early in his career the fans
are going to be very upset the people
who buy the tickets aren't happy if the
guy's not there anymore that's why
having multiple running backs is the
best way to go because you never create
that one guy that everybody buys the
jersey and every kid wants to be him and
the end result is you get backed into a
corner and you have to pay him when
maybe your best play would be to let him
walk away or
finish his rookie contract do the
franchise tag one year and then move on
from the player and that's what the
steelers did now the steelers could move
back in you know there are other teams
that could be interested matt naggy the
coach of the bears didn't rule it out
earlier this afternoon the coach of the
eagles doug peterson seemed to but i
think somebody will sign him at some
point and if not he just waits and you
wait because at some point some running
back is going to get injured we know
that and it's going to open the door for
le'veon bell the door is now closed on
bell with the jets here's adam gase the
head coach from earlier today on the
question of whether or not bell was
misused in the jets offense
do you agree with the perception that
you misused him
it's irrelevant at this point
yeah but i you know adam when a team
makes a
free agent investment that large and it
ends before two seasons i think the fans
are interested in knowing why it didn't
work out with a player of that stature
yeah it didn't work out it didn't work
out and we're gonna focus on this game
right now
they know other coaches with
more accomplishments on their resume
would say that and nobody would say boo
adam gase says it and the people out
there who don't like him automatically
start blaming him but you know what his
it is irrelevant
whether or not he was misused here's the
problem and and i think gace is trying
to protect some people in this regard
the problem is they never should have
signed him for the money they signed him
for their offense wasn't ready for a
running back their offense wasn't a
running back away from being a great
attack and you don't go out and add a
great running back when you don't have
an offensive line when you don't have a
quarterback who's at the point where you
say yeah that's a potential franchise
guy and we don't have the receivers it
can't be a one-man show unless it's
barry sanders and le'veon bell is not
barry sanders where he can get 100 yards
a game without any help around him like
sanders consistently did you need more
and to pay 13.5 million a year when
there was no one else north of 10
million they got duped by the notion
that the ravens were going to pay bell
in that stratosphere and
my sense is that
people in the organization were trying
to tell macagnan you're you're you're
the subject of a ruse here but they
still were determined to pay 13.5
million a year this thing was doing from
the start the offense was never good
enough to get the most out of bell and
they paid him too much money and
once it got out that gays thought they
paid him too much money that poisoned
the relationship by all appearances
between gays and bell
and that's been the problem mike is this
is a bad offense and it's not a good
team and when you start looking at
players on that team that that you would
take to build a team around there just
aren't many of them and sam darnold's
not one of them either which is why they
face
many many problems but this just seems
like a team that's been circling the
drain for for a long time and they may
actually be flushed after this year
because probably going to have a new
head coach and i can already see the
headline in the new york post it's
probably going to repeat what adam gase
just said it you know didn't get the job
done didn't work out i think we're his
exact word so didn't work out because
this probably isn't going to work out
for him they'll have a new coach maybe
even a new gm who knows but they
they're a long way off from being a good
team and you're right you don't go sign
a running back when you're a long way
off
the one thing that doesn't get discussed
nearly enough and i don't understand why
the idea that woody johnson may be back
sooner rather than later from his
assignment as the u.s ambassador to the
uk he could tell everybody go he could
tell his brother get out of here you
made a mess of this i'm taking over
again and we're going to see what we can
do and people think joe douglas is
permanently safe i don't get it because
douglas was gases hand-picked guy so if
douglas is
golden his opinion on gays should be
golden 2 and douglas isn't going to want
gays to go because gase picked douglas
and that's just a weird dynamic that
doesn't get discussed enough either so
who knows who knows maybe maybe gase
gets another chance to try to rebuild
this thing at some point though
the fact that the panthers
are thriving as they rebuild makes it
look horrible for the jets to be as bad
as they are and again four more games
until the bye and if they don't get a
win in the next four weeks i think it
could be end of the road for gays during
the
season hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports